[Music]
hmm
[Music]
yeah if you don't care
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
i appreciate that
hey have you been in here
[Music]
there one three we're gonna need more
uniforms
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
1102 weinbach is clear
[Music]
we've been in
[Music]
here all
[Music]
i need everybody on scene to go east
be advised we do not have anybody to
monitor
claire mark 1012 north weinbach it's
clear
clear
dispatch 10
15 northwind
it's clear
clear you've been a 10-11
all right in ralph we're moving all pd
traffic is going to motor pro he's just
find somebody monitored
i'll advise our supervisor of that
air 130
who lives here
hey guys center point just advise that
line should be still hot just be aware
okay
what about here
i haven't got there yet
air one three one thousand seven it's
clear
[Music]
huh
dogs are there
hey
it's broke anyways
where do you need cars exactly
we're just trying to clear
houses or
okay
is
[Music]
please
[Music]
1002 and 1004 are clear
figure out 10 on 100
police department
captain
i'm with the chief the chief wants
everything blocked off at columbia
and weinbach police department
completely cleared off no traffic nobody
on that road whatsoever to the west of
the scene
he watched everything shut down all the
way back to
weinbach and oak hill
and then one block to the east of this
location
[Music]
air one three one thousand nine is clear
okay one thousand nine is quick
we're good this way
we did not make contact with the great
house
location
[Music]
uh
is
[Music]
so all these people that are sitting
here taking pictures and doing this shit
unless they live at a residence where we
need to talk to them
get out of here
i need everybody who's not
involved
[Music]
if there's a house that's being cleared
we need to put tape in front of it so we
can keep track
all these bodies need to be on the other
side of bubble four to five
[Music]
to push everybody that's not involved in
this on the other side of boulder
did you guys down here
go
go
go
yes i need tape if
in front of the houses on wine box that
have been cleared for sure
i also need tape down here at beauville
the line's going to be at vogel at
weinbach
there should be a piece of hate laying
right in front of the amr just to the
south arm wine box
i got that i need you to help me string
this up over here
10 17 hercules has been cleared
i need this line all these people that
aren't involved
1001 is refusing to leave at this time
i appreciate that but they don't have a
choice that's my order
i'm clear we'll go back to it
everybody on the other side of mogul all
right
you want to go across uh yeah
hold that
hang on let me go across
[Music]
i'm going all the way to that stop sign
down there
what are you driving all the way that
stops
i'll move my truck out um
you're gonna block that off we're just
gonna make sure nobody's crawling
well i left enough room for him
i appreciate it
he might need prime team take me back
10 21 hercules has been cleared
anybody got a crime scene log or that we
can go ahead and get started you're
gonna have to get a couple sheets at
least
made you all on the other side of this
tank
[Applause]
[Music]
um swine back here on the left side
knees block off i think turkey leaving
okay
fly back guys
slide back
[Music]
no worries
no idea
[Music]
1001 is evacuating now
i have no idea bud
are uh
they're either leaving or they've been
checked so right behind the scene on
hercules all these houses been checked
okay they think there still may be a
leak so make sure that hercules is
there's no one on her to eat that
everyone is out of the area
hey do i have an investigator on here i
got the guys in the house next door
we got center point here at weinbach and
oak hill where do you want them
hey can i get one to check down here and
one locking bell air for me
hi
what do you guys want to help me
we're putting on we've already cleared
this house okay everybody
what are you just
going to tie it off over there on that
pole they've already checked this look
out have you guys checked we've checked
all that over there
up here down to the last night
and said somebody's employees are inside
and reporting damage to the building
somebody can check on them
all right we'll check it
i'll out there in just a second if
you're up close
we got plenty of people over here
you can pass it along
anything with tape on it has been
cleared it looks like it's going to be
columbia lincoln park where i need
anybody know where that live wire is at
they want to be shown so we can shut
down
the wire
on the ground
from the lot south of 1102
i don't know if it's still connected or
not
you could probably use the car in
columbia don't kill
yeah what val
yeah
has anybody started the crime scene yet
[Music]
you guys
hercules
1102 wine box
dispatches anybody can make contact with
the school and let them know
that
and then i don't know about that but
we're walking across this line here
there's electric guys there with the
poles
so this is the wire that they were
talking about
that they're worried about and then
obviously the wire here got you okay so